[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
inflation remains stuck at 8.7 percent
increasing pressure on the bank of
England to carry on raising interest
rates
more bad news for public finances as
national debt hits 100 of GDP for the
first time since 1961. three billion
dollars of loans announced to help
Ukraine rebuild we're here from the
World Bank about how it will be spent
plus the chief executive of the 21
billion dollar Financial Services giant
Raymond James on plans to expand in the
UK
foreign
King live in our business and economic
news from the Heart of the City well the
headline rate of inflation in the UK
unexpectedly failed to fall last month
increasing pressure on the bank of
England's monetary policy committee to
deliver a larger than anticipated
increase in the cost of borrowing
tomorrow Consumer Price inflation in May
came in at 8.7 percent that was
unchanged on April City economists had
been expecting to see a decline to 8.4
percent contributing to the number with
significant increases in the price of
airfares package holidays tickets for
live music events games particularly
computer games toys and hobbies the bank
of England is now Under Pressure to
raise its main policy rate tomorrow from
four and a half percent to five percent
instead of the previously expected four
and three-quarter percent
if we're going to help families if we're
going to relieve the pressure on people
with mortgages on businesses we need to
squeeze every last drop of high
inflation out of the economy and if you
look at what's happening in other
countries you can see that rises in
interest rates do bring down inflation
over time that will happen here but we
need to be patient we need to stick to
the course and then we'll get to the
other side
joining me now is our business
correspondent Paul Kelso Paul
interesting to note that food and drink
inflation did come down during the month
but other things have gone much higher
yeah and there's the troubling figures
behind the headline figure in which as
you say uh stuck stubbornly at 8.7 for
the Consumer Price inflation uh index
measure of inflation static uh an
example uh right before our eyes of the
the stickiness is the word we've been
using isn't it but inflation failing to
come down despite the two biggest
drivers certainly at the start of the
global inflation Spike was Energy prices
well that inflation is falling and food
price inflation which has been
maintaining these high levels certainly
not Rising as fast but if we go below
that headline number and look at core
inflation which is exactly what will be
happening at the bank of England and at
the treasury and elsewhere so in the
city today core inflation is rising up
to 7.1 percent that's up 0.3 on April
it's been rising since March and what
that indicates is despite taking out the
global external factors of food and
energy internal UK domestic inflation
driven by things like Services the cost
of goods and services all rising in the
year to May and also wage inflation we
were talking about this last week and
this was a figure that spooked the
markets and set expectations for
interest rates higher last week wage
inflation up 7.2 percent there might now
be a debate about whether this is a sign
of a price wage spiral or a wage price
spiral which way round those come will
inform the policy choices that are made
but nevertheless it's indicative that
inflation is becoming embedded in the
jargon that's been the fear since the
start of this that the external factors
would fade but the rising prices that
very tight labor market would push wages
up and those two factors would feed each
other what does it mean it means for
tomorrow it feels like it's cementing a
rise in interest rates tomorrow the
markets are now exp the expectation now
for the peak of interest rates has risen
this morning to six percent by the end
of the year it's 4.5 five percent the
base rate today expecting at least a
point two five percentage Point uh rise
tomorrow perhaps half a percentage point
being pushed for that the markets
believe that the peak has risen that's
risen has also as two-year guilt yield
number that we've been watching ever
since the mini budget yesterday it went
past in fact last week uh the the post
Liz trust Peak it's risen again this
morning the markets are not uh not happy
about this we've heard the chancellor
there uh in our introduction talking
about how he's going to back the bank of
England well there's a political Pledge
on this as well the government has
pledged to bring down inflation uh by
half by the end of the year also to grow
the economy and to cut government debt
and all three of those pledges are
looking uh uh a more questionable Target
than perhaps they did when they were
made so there's political prices perhaps
today was a very real price to be paid
by homeowners and consumers before then
okay thanks Paul
all the inflation data was not the only
Grim piece of news concerning the UK
economy this morning the office for
National statistics also reported that
the UK's national debt has risen above
100 of GDP for the first time since
1961. well that was a result of
government borrowing in May coming in at
20.05 billion pounds that was higher
than the 18.3 billion pounds that have
been expected by the office for Budget
responsibility and more than Economist
estimates of around 19 and a half
billion pounds it means the UK's
national debt now stands at 2.567
trillion pounds for joining me now is
Liz Martin She's UK Economist at HSBC
Liz good to see you this morning uh Paul
was talking there about the core
inflation uh figure which rose to 7.1 I
guess that's the biggest cause of
concern right now for the bank of
England
yeah it is it's definitely court and
services inflation so this is what the
boe's really been focused on and of
course that makes sense there's not much
the Boe can do about you know gas supply
uh anything like that and the bit that
it's concerned with is is the bit that
reflects supply and demand conditions
right here in the UK
um and core inflation
um as you as you state has risen to over
seven percent now and that really marks
us out in the UK actually because if we
look to other kind of developed markets
if you look to us and Eurozone
um their core inflation numbers are not
only a bit lower 5.3 they're also the
lines are pointing downwards whereas the
UK chart unfortunately continues to push
higher
when you look at that Global comparison
Liz I mean a lot of the inflation that
we're seeing here in the UK is being put
down to the tightness in the labor
market what sort of levels of wage
inflation are we seeing in the US and
across Europe
definitely slowing down I mean much much
lower I think if a context you know the
UK wage number was 7.6 six percent um in
the most recent reading private sector
regular pay
um in the US it's more like in the fours
Eurozone potentially even kind of lower
than that but you know there are
different factors
um and in some ways you know this is a
problem of success that the UK has you
know the UK economy in the three months
to April created a quarter of a million
jobs that came as a surprise to me it
wasn't what the surveys were suggesting
um but it does show that you know demand
in this country is still pretty strong
as well as that constrained Supply
picture so for the UK it feels like
everything that countries around the
world are struggling on is just a little
bit Amplified whether it's weak labor
Supply strong labor demand poor
productivity
um you know all these things it just
feels like it's a little bit more
intense here in the UK and the result is
that very high inflation number so where
does this leave the MPC tomorrow do they
go for the quarter point high court do
they go for the sort of full fat half a
point
well I think certainly a few members
will be voting for uh the full fight
half a point I think we you know we've
as a base case put that three members
would uh would vote for that but the
issue is will the governor and the other
and the deputy Governors the kind of
internal members of the committee also
have seen this inflation number and we
know they saw it on on Monday so they
had a bit of time to process
um and said actually do you know what 25
isn't going to be enough we do need to
go further we've had this is the fourth
consecutive month where inflation has
surprised to the upside right economists
have gone all right inflation's a bit
higher now so we'll we'll forecast a
high number but even relative to those
forecasts
um it's come in higher so has the Boe
reconsidered I think there's a lot of
pressure on them you know we just saw
um Jeremy Hunt saying you know we'll
back the Boe to do whatever it takes to
bring inflation
um back down
um so that's um that's one thing it's
interesting that the market though is
still pricing a relatively low chance
that they do go to half a point um
tomorrow
um and perhaps that's because the bank
of England historically has proceeded in
a much more cautious
um fashion so it's it's really hard to
call I think um there are good arguments
then on on both sides but certainly on
the back of this number
um the risks of a larger move have
certainly risen
Liz what about the terminal rate where
where uh rates peak in this uh monetary
tightening cycle what's your thinking on
that now
so our forecast is 5 25 and clearly as
um your colleague just mentioned the
Market's gone further and and predicting
now the six percent Mark um it is
possible of course that they do have to
go
um higher still I think all the way
through this cycle you know we've we've
predicted one thing and inflation has
continued to surprise to the upside and
we've had to revise hire those um those
forecasts for the end game ultimately
for the Boe to stop hiking they need to
see some evidence that their prediction
of a fall back in in core inflation and
services inflation
um is coming good and and so far all the
evidence is very kind of um soft you
know it's it's it's it's not hard
evidence things like the surveys
suggesting that the the pressure in the
labor market is easing
um it's not enough they need to see that
pay growth coming down they need to
start seeing you know core inflation
easing off it doesn't have to get all
the way back down to Target but it has
to look like it's at least moving in the
right direction and um you know if it's
not doing that by September when we
forecast our final rate rise then then
you know clearly risk that they have to
continue and do more and certainly you
know unlike some I think we're not
expecting any any Cuts you know either
this year or next I don't think
inflation is going to allow them to do
that oh crocodiles you're going to have
the viewers uh throwing themselves off
the window Ledges at this rate
good to see you this morning thank you
now today sees the start of the 2023
Ukraine recovery conference which is
bringing together members of the
International Community to mobilize
support for the rebuilding of the
country in the last hour the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak announced a major
Financial package for the Ukraine
including three billion dollars worth of
loan guarantees well there's already
been plenty of short-term emergency
assistance for Ukraine but broader
support from the private sector and
financial institutions is going to be
needed to support longer-term
reconstruction I've been speaking with
Anna beard managing director for
operations at the World Bank
the World Bank has provided significant
support to Ukraine I'll speak you know
we're a world bank group I'll speak on
behalf of the World Bank here where I'm
managing director for operations so
since the war started we have mobilized
about 25 billion dollars for Ukraine of
which we have dispersed meaning executed
about 23 billion so funds that have been
received in Ukraine by Ukraine and we
have really focused since the start of
the war on financing the essential
social expenditures of the budget but
are now also moving into financing what
we call repair and Recovery projects in
sectors such as energy transport
agriculture housing as well as health
and Health Services what about the total
bill for repairing and rebuilding
Ukraine's economy I've seen figures as
high as 400 billion dollars circulating
is it possible to get a handle on it
yes so um the uh last estimate that we
did in our rapid damage and needs
assessment indeed put the Reconstruction
needs of Ukraine at 411 billion dollars
which is a sort of estimate spanning a
10-year reconstruction period but uh to
make it more meaningful what we all also
did was actually estimate priority needs
for the next 12 months and that number
is 14 billion where we would very much
like to see this these funds deployed
for priority repair and Recovery
projects in the country
and when you're looking at the the kind
of work that needs to be done obviously
the situation is changing very fast I
mean for example the kakovka
hydroelectric Dam has just been blown up
by the Russians presumably that was
something that wouldn't necessarily have
been factored into previous estimates
yes indeed Ian uh you know things are
Dynamic so we will be updating our rapid
damage and needs assessment again at the
end of this calendar year coming out in
early 24 with a new number but in the
meantime when we have incidents like the
kahokia dam or in the fall when the
energy infrastructure was targeted we
also do uh continuously rapid damage and
needs assessments and we have actually
just completed an estimate a very rapid
estimate of the dam that we will be
discussing over the next few days you've
also been doing some work into the
impact of the war on Ukraine's private
sector tell me about that yes yes so we
just did a firm survey which actually
showed some very interesting results we
served about 2 000 domestic firms and
about 80 or so multinational companies
and what we found of course companies
have suffered Revenue loss employment
changes but what we found was actually
quite encouraging which is that about
four out of five companies have stayed
operating during the war and only about
so that's about 80 and only about four
percent of firms have completely shut
down so this actually is very
encouraging for us of course they've had
to adapt significantly they've changed
product makes they've relied on ICT they
have relocated within the country
towards the west of the country but
overall we're actually quite encouraged
because it means that there's resilience
also at the firm level in Ukraine
and those companies that are staying to
do business in Ukraine I presume that a
lot of them are from countries which are
of supporters of Ukraine the EU the
United States and so forth what about
those countries that have been slightly
more ambivalent such as India and China
who of course continuing to buy Russian
crude
yes so the of the firms that we surveyed
most of them 2000 in fact are domestic
firms and I think the domestic private
sector in Ukraine is very very important
because these are the smaller and
medium-sized companies that also
generate a lot of the employment in the
country now what we found was
International firms that were active in
Ukraine before the war are still very
interested in staying engaged and have
stayed engaged even though they've
adapted and changed so of course there's
always concentration when you look at
investments in the country but overall
we find that the support for Ukraine is
strong of course there are always
tensions we are seeing them due
political tensions but all on the survey
of the firms we're actually encouraged
because the domestic private sector is
important and the international
companies are standing with Ukraine of
course during the war but also hoping
for the opportunities that will come
with recovery and full reconstruction
some other business news stories for you
now and the house Builder Barclay group
this morning criticized changes the
government is proposing to make to the
National planning policy framework the
changes were part of a compromise agreed
by the housing secretary Michael Gove
last December to water down local
housing targets following pressure from
conservative benches but Barclay which
specializes in regeneration projects
said today the proposed changes would
materially reduce the pace of delivery
of new homes and said there was already
evidence of that happening the UK's
second biggest house Builder by stock
market value was reporting a pre-tax
profit of 604 million pounds for the
year to the end of April up nine and a
half percent on the previous 12 months
but it also warned that sales this year
will be down a fifth
the trucks giant GSK said today that
it's vaccine for Respiratory Sensational
virus or RSV had proved effective in
providing longer-term protection recent
trials for patients age 60 or older the
vaccine caller XV was approved for
medical use in the United States and the
EU last month and it's the first RSV
vaccine for older adults to be approved
anywhere in the world GSK said today the
shot had shown itself capable of
providing protection over two full
seasons RSV results in the
hospitalization of 177 000 people aged
over the 65 in the us alone each year
around 14 000 of whom are killed by the
virus
and Halfords has reported a big drop in
annual profits as consumers reigned in
spending in response to the cost of
living crisis underlying pre-tax profits
for the year to the end of March came in
at 51.5 million pounds that was down 43
on the previous 12 months well Graham
Stapleton the chief executive said like
for like cycling sales were down nearly
11 on the previous 12 months although
motoring sales were up four percent I
can tell shares of Halfords are ahead by
five percent right now and that is on
assurances that profits are going to be
higher this year
foreign
has seen some very interesting movements
this morning following the high event
anticipated inflation data Sterling
briefly jumps on the figure but they'll
fell back on concerns that what another
big interest rate rise might do to the
economy the pan now off nearly
two-fifths of one percent against the US
dollar and it's off by a similar amount
against the Euro The single currency
meanwhile unchanged against the dollar
on the equity markets wall Street's
declines last night were followed by
mixed trade in the Asia Pacific region
only the turbocharged Nikkei in Tokyo
was ahead of the major indices in the
region in Europe stocks have been pretty
mixed this morning here's the current
picture actually only the Kakarot in
Paris now in negative territory talking
points this morning include Lufthansa
the shares there up by some one and a
half percent in Frankfurt and that was
after the airline sold its payment
subsidiary to the Swedish Bank Seb for
450 million euros we're here in London
the ftse 100 is more or less unchanged
right now it hit a three-week low
earlier on this morning on the back of
the inflation data they're not a
terribly High number of features for
Traders to hang their hats on this
morning with all of the house builders
are lower on the comments from Barclays
there you go Barclay itself offer nearly
two and a quarter percent there's a bit
more going on among the mid caps today
outside the ftse alpha Financial the
shares ahead by just over five percent
that's after it agreed to a takeover by
the private Equity Firm eqt valuing it
at just over 614 million pounds I mean
while the online beauty products
retailer thg the Huck Group shares ahead
there by some three percent asset
forecast to rise in half-year profits to
the downside the asset manager lion
trust you recall we've had the CEO of
that company on the program in the
recent past it's off by some two and a
quarter percent after reporting a drop
in annual profits meanwhile the wealth
manager rathbones it Shares are off by
five and three quarter percent that is
on adverse broker comment as for the oil
price well it rallied earlier on in the
session it's more or less unchanged
right now Battle of Brent crude will
currently set you back 75 dollars not 91
cents a barrel as I say more or less
unchanged joining me now is Rachel
winter partner at killer can go Rachel
good to see you this morning obviously
um inflation now was disappointing I was
quite baffled by what the pound did I
mean the pound has always gone higher on
these inflation numbers but it's it's
come off a bit this morning it has so
the inflation number was disappointing
we didn't see the drop in inflation that
we hoped for and that means that
interest rates are likely to go up
tomorrow normally that would be good
news for the pound because money tends
to follow higher interest rates but the
fact that inflation is high and the fact
that government debt was higher than
expected I think has damage confidence
in the UK economy potentially that's why
the pound's been about volatile this
morning yeah I mean the public finances
a lot of that is down to interest
payments which reflect the fact that uh
a proportion of debt is interest
payments are linked to inflation exactly
so about 25 of UK government debt is
linked to the RPI rate of inflation
which is very high it's over 11 at the
moment so that really is a concern there
was also some big pay Rises pushed
through in um I think there was a big
NHS thing that that looks like it's
contributed to the number being slightly
higher than expected it does so the
government borrowing for me was 20
billion pounds which was higher than
expected and the reason given was that
wages have gone up what about corporate
features today Barclay group obviously
the biggest of the uh of the companies
reporting today I mean the I thought the
results were a bit of a mixed bag really
could say
well the results were not bad I thought
they were actually quite good so we're
in line with the guidance that was given
last December but I think no one's
really looking at those numbers they're
just thinking what's this company going
to do in the future and that really
depends on interest rates and if
interest rates are going up that's bad
news for house builders that's really
going to hit demand for houses yeah I
thought there was an interesting line in
their statement they haven't built uh
bought any land they've not added to
their land Holdings yeah so they've said
they've been very cautious they've
bought a lot of land over the last
decades they probably have enough to be
getting on with but they are expecting
less demand so that means they'll need
less land in the future sadly so what
about Halfords I mean they had three
different iterations of the profit
number and comparisons going all the way
back to Cove pre-covered I mean it was
hard to make sense of them almost it was
so profits clearly down a lot compared
to last year but still profitable which
is a good thing I think the results were
better than expected because the shares
are quite heavily up this morning I
think it's what what's quite interesting
is how the divisions of the company have
changed over the last few years so
during covert we had this massive boom
in cycling and then lack of demand for
anything car related and now we've got
the opposite so cycling and
discretionary spend are really dropping
off but people are trying to hold on to
their older cars for longer and that's
good for the service related bit of
Halfords and we must talk about uh The
Hub Group I mean for what for once they
don't seem to have disappointed
investors no I think that the profits
were better than expected but I think
what's really got investors excited is
the corporate governance issue so there
has been some concern about this golden
share that the founder had that gave him
extra special votes this morning it has
been announced that he's got rid of that
and that potentially means the company
could be more open to a takeover yeah
big news that Rachel good leave it I'm
afraid good to see you this morning
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
while managing the monthly payroll is
Big Business don't go away
[Music]
so there was a shortage of pathologist
prior to cover with an aging population
of existing Pathologists but it's not a
national problem it's an international
problem so you can't just go and recruit
Pathologists from other countries and it
takes about 10 years to train a junior
up to consultant level we have
um changed the conventional way that we
do pathology traditionally you'd look
through a microscope at some slides to
try and look for changes in structure to
identify cause and effects in diseases
and what we've been able to do over the
past few years is take that slide image
put it on the cloud allow any doctor
anywhere in the world that is qualified
to be able to provide a diagnosis the
add-on from that is artificial
intelligence you can now have the image
analyzed by an algorithm for either
primary or secondary read so primary
read it will assist the pathologist in
being able to provide the diagnosis by
high alerting key areas that build up
the characteristics of a cancer data set
and so rather than pathologist having to
actually identify on the slide where
these characteristics are the algorithm
will display them directly the second
way is through a second read so quality
assurance to mitigate misdiagnosis as
every single cancer is diagnosed you can
have the algorithms working in the
background to Quality check and assist
the doctor and provide an audit of cases
that have already been reported so I
think the biggest problem is the
infrastructure costs so you'll need to
get iot lines into the hospitals because
each image is around 500 megabytes
you'll need Cloud infrastructure you'll
need servers for archiving of images to
come back to them in the future
and then you'll need communication
between the various pieces of software
that the NHS use there's not one
singular software that each Hospital
uses so you'll need different laboratory
Information Management Systems talking
to Imaging systems talking to different
AI providers and so the costs will add
up
welcome back now running the monthly
payroll is one of the most complicated
but important tasks any business faces
it's also time consuming research
suggest HR and finance professionals
spend an average of nearly five days a
month on managing payroll supporting
Employers in that task is big business
with the likes of the ftse 100 member
Sage among the major players well the
latest to join the field here is San
Francisco based Rippling which after its
latest funding round was valued at 11
and a half billion dollars it's just
opened offices in London and Dublin and
I've been speaking with its founder and
chief executive Parker Conrad
Ripley's basically an all-in-one system
to manage your employees so think you
know payroll HR things like annual
leaves pensions as well as some other
stuff like managing sort of I.T and
device security shipping new joiners
their computers
expense reimbursements and things like
that and what sort of revenues are you
targeting
um in the UK specifically we're we're
just getting started so we um we uh we
have a core group of about you know two
dozen people or so and and plan to
roughly triple the head count over the
next year how do you think the markets
are going to differ from the United
States
you know it's interesting I think that
there's one of the things we found is
that there's
um in in some ways an even bigger
administrative burden on UK companies
than what we see in the United States
um it uh you know in the UK people spend
an enormous amount of time just dealing
with payroll for their businesses
because all of these systems are
disconnected so you've got a you know
manage data often from spreadsheets
sometimes from an hris system to get
into payroll you've got you know other
things to deal with like annual leaves
and then Bank files you need to transfer
your Bank Ripley that's all one system
so you just go in everything's
pre-calculated for you you click a
button and the money's off you don't
even have to deal with the banking
system you can have a lot of HR and
finance professionals uh looking
anxiously over their shoulder at this
right I don't think so because I think
that what you know look no one likes to
be spending their time on administrative
work there's a lot that people could be
doing you know real HR focused on sort
of you know making the business more
effective right rather than you know
dealing with payroll Bank files who
wants to spend their time on that we've
just had obviously a quite prominent
hacking incident involving uh payroll
software how I mean cyber security must
be a massive priority for you it's it's
absolutely critical it's existential for
a business like ours um one of the
interesting things is that Rippling
because of our sort of slightly broader
mandate because we spend a lot of time
managing employees and back office
functions more broadly than HR in it as
well we think of ourselves as a security
company first and foremost and so
um we you know we we do what's
traditionally called identity software
things like single sign-on and managing
users and different apps that use for
your company device management security
software on devices on laptops and
things like that so we've got sort of a
deep background in in the security space
in addition to the payroll in HR one now
you raised 500 million dollars back in
March it's a series e funding round I
mean that was around the time of silicon
Valley Banks collapse you had a lot of
money on deposit there gather we did
yeah so we we most of our banking rails
in the United States were moving through
Silicon Valley Bank at the time that
they went under
um and so what happened is uh you know I
woke up one Friday morning and uh
discovered that that it was it was
payday and discovered that a lot of
these funds were frozen in receivership
at Silicon Valley Bank and so what we
made a sort of a very snap and sort of
somewhat risky decision that we were
going to sort of to make sure that
people got paid we were going to wire
about 130 million dollars of our own
company money over to JPMorgan Chase to
make sure that funds went out the door
because the actual payroll funds for
these companies were stuck at svb
um and so we fronted a lot of the
capital as part of that to make sure
that you know we would we would sort of
be able to backstop that we did a very
quick fundraising round called up some
investors that had wanted to uh invest
in in riplane for a long time and
negotiated in just a few hours and and
got the round closed that weekend and of
course you know over the course of the
weekend
um uh the FDIC announced that they would
make all depositors whole and so it
ended up not being necessary but we were
prepared just in case so does that means
you've you've actually got a bit more
Capital probably than you were you were
looking for at that time we do the
business is extremely well funded we've
got a you know about a billion dollars
of uh of of capital on hand so svb was
it a matter of life and death for weeks
it sounds like you were going to be able
to make payroll anyway regardless
um I I don't think it was necessarily a
matter of life and death but we felt we
felt very strongly that although the svb
collapse was not our fault it was
definitely our responsibility to ensure
that everyone got paid and so in the
United States the way this works is that
companies send payroll funds to their
payroll company in in this case us a few
days ahead of payday and then we then
send the money onto employees into
various tax agencies and government
authorities and so there's this window
where we're actually in in possession of
the payroll funds and that was when you
know when svb went under there was money
that was sort of in flight and that was
what we wanted to make sure that that we
would be able to we want to make sure
that money went out to hundreds of
thousands of employees around the states
fascinating conversation that I'm sure
we'll be hearing from him again well
still to come here on in King live I'm
going to be joined by the chief
executive of the financial services
giant Raymond James don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back now there's been a good
deal of consolidation in the UK wealth
management sector in recent times with
rathbones announcing plans for emerging
with investec wealth and investment in
April and Bruin dolphin last year
agreeing a takeover by RBC of Canada
last summer before both of those deals
though came the 279 million pound
takeover of the 229 year old institution
Charles Stanley by the U.S financial
services giant Raymond James and the
latter is still looking to expand its
presence here in the UK we're joining me
now is Paul Reilly chief executive of
Raymond James Paul very good to see you
this morning or even before you bought
Charles down you you'd moved your
European Investment Banking headquarters
to London you obviously like the UK yeah
we do we've been here 30 years but in
2017 you know kind of brexit we made the
plans to to be centered here in London
and still like that and are doubling
down where we have new leases both in
the city and Mayfair don't like the rent
in Mayfair but uh but you know beautiful
locations and we're continuing to grow
and London is an important market for us
how big do you see your UK wealth
management business becoming we're
hoping that over time we become top five
if you look at our position in the U.S
and Canada we're five six however you
want to create the chart to show where
you are you know we're somewhere in
there and we want to be a significant
player in London so job number one is
first integrate the two firms we we
don't say we acquire somebody they join
the family and so we're looking at
taking the best of what Charles Stanley
has to offer the best of what we did in
Raymond James and use the best Solutions
and then integrate them for both parts
of the firm so we're right smack in the
middle of that still yeah obviously
wealth managers have a bit of a line to
walk between trying to cut cost by
better use of technology and the fact
that a lot of customers still want that
sort of face-to-face contact with
advisors how are you managing that well
I think it's a combination our our job
is to try to keep the back office cost
make it very efficient the there's cost
pressure by funds by families but it's
interesting that the wealth managers
fees haven't been under pressure and U.S
Canada and here people are willing to
pay for that personal holistic advice so
our job is to deliver it to them better
so we're our technology spent in wealth
management has gone up from maybe 100
million to 750 million over the last few
years we've been using AI for a number
of years in the back office and now on
the apps and hoping to bring that
technology that we're using in the U.S
and Canada to integrate it in a way that
it makes sense for the UK and their
offerings how disruptive do you see some
of these Robo advisors obviously we've
got names like nutmeg bought by JPMorgan
Chase of course very active in the
market did you see them as a threat to
what you're you're trying to achieve
when they first came out people said
they put us out of business and
self-directed trading was going to put
us out of business and never took it
that way if you look at the biggest Robo
advisors their average account balance
is three thousand dollars so we're in
the Financial Planning and wealth
planning business there's not much you
can do with three thousand dollars but
tell people to put it into an ETF or a
broad fund so the technology types of
applications for the user were
integrating into our platform I think
they'll be table Stakes but going to a
robo advice and even when we see AI
we're using AI on the desktop today
where advisors in the US can when they
turn on their computer they can see
things that are happening in the
portfolios AI actually will go in and
say these bonds are coming to you or you
need these payments or your portfolio is
drifting you need to rebalance them and
that'll get more and more powerful but
so technology is going to be important
but that human touch is still what gets
the client to actually do something
about it now wealth management is only
one aspect of what the broader Raymond
James group does I mean you also have a
lot of big corporate and institutional
clients as well how do the sort of
revenues break down between the various
activities well uh globally we're about
11 billion overall about a billion eight
last year was in the institutional part
of the business so first and foremost
we're a wealth manager but we have a
very very strong Middle Market m a
business here in London we have the 75
people and growing in the city and then
Germany we where we bought a firm called
mummer we've tripled it it's about 35
and growing and so we we really did that
to integrate the U.S Canadian and
European M A deals because they more and
more became cross-border and certainly
enough it's really taken off because of
that the other interesting part is where
M A's down all over it's down a lot less
in in the UK and Europe where the U.S
had you know all record highs it's come
way down we're starting to see it kind
of return but Europe's been much more
steady and we're still trying to grow
and add people here yeah it's very
interesting that I mean talking of the
US so obviously there's a lot of concern
about the extent to which the fed's been
tightening monetary policy is it going
to drive the us into a recession what's
your thinking yeah you know you look at
it and you say how much can you keep
raising rates and first part is you know
five percent six percent rates
historically are not large now two
percent inflation has only been a very
small
time in history so I think their targets
are too tight certainly that I get
inflation down because life was getting
almost unaffordable with food and fuel
for the average person
so hopefully now the numbers are showing
inflation finally you know has come down
the last few quarters
um and so you can say that tightening
and tightening and lending will impact
the economy but it's hard to have a big
recession when everyone's employed and
there's still a war for talent people
you know the pay gaps even Between Women
minorities everything are tightening you
can see the market tightening so as long
as people have money and they're willing
to spend it it's hard to see a big
recession so you know you can argue both
sides and we don't know we'll see where
this all lands all right positive note
on which to end Paul good to see you
this morning thank you
[Music]
have a look at this morning's business
pages
the financial times reports on its front
page that Abu Dhabi Sovereign wealth
fund adq held detailed talks to take the
Investment Bank Lazard private it
splashes its print edition with the
report that the chancellor Jeremy Hunt
is to call in the banks for talks
overspiring UK mortgage costs well that
also makes the lead in the business
pages of the Daily Telegraph which
highlights the Chancellor's insistence
that there are no plans to push lenders
to change the products that they offer
borrowers Telegraph also reports on its
business front page that National
savings and Investments has raised its
premium bonds prize fund rate to 3.7
percent that is the highest level in 15
years well the times leads its business
pages with news that wh Smith has been
ordered to pay more than one million
pounds to thousands of its employees and
that was after a requirement to provide
their own uniforms for salaries below
the national minimum wage it was among
202 companies named and chained by the
department for business for
short-changing staff between 2017 and
and 2019 times also reports that
clothing supplies landlords and lenders
to Debenhams are set to lose 1.3 billion
pounds that they were owed when the
retailer collapsed in December 2020.
now there are lots of theories as to why
the UK doesn't build more houses the
planning regime is one that was singled
out today by Barclay group labor
shortages in the construction industry
is another but my next guest argues a
third factor is the refusal of banks to
lend to SME house builders joining me
now is Simon Champy's chief executive at
newstead Capital Simon welcome to I mean
that's quite an assertion what evidence
do you have for that
well I think I think there's a couple of
things that happened and I think Barclay
a right to a degree planning doesn't
help labor doesn't help but for me one
of the biggest factors by mile was
poster GFC we we brought out new
regulation to help effectively help
protect Banks from themselves and that
regulation did a few really good things
but it did have some unintended
consequences one of those key unintended
consequences was cutting off the supply
of capital to particularly to SME house
builders it's interesting to hear
Barclays comments because larger house
builders have access to bond markets to
equities they have sophisticated Finance
directors they have lots of resources
financially smaller house builders in
Derby Mansfield Exeter Hull do not have
that they don't have access to Capital
so by Banks reducing access to to that
kind of capitalist throttled the amount
of homes we built why do you think the
banks are so conservative
I don't think a lot of it wasn't their
choice banking regulation was put in
place post to GFC to protect us all from
Bank excess and to protect the banks
from themselves and it was Blanket
regulation and it made certain types of
loans in particular drawdown loans that
are that a house Builder might use very
difficult if you think about a house
builder's model it's pretty simple
he will pretty simply buy a piece of
land and hope to get planning as Barclay
said they may or may not get planning
once he has planning on that piece of
land he then needs to borrow the money
to build the houses hopefully makes a
profit and hopefully pays back the house
Builder if he can't borrow the money in
the middle of that chain he won't apply
for planning and he won't build any
homes and this is happening up and down
the UK particularly I think and some of
the leveling up areas of the country
where it might be sort of less
attractive to build houses per se
um so we're seeing smaller Builders
starved of capital all across the
country not building homes there's one
quite startling fact if I might might
say be pre the GFC sort of in the 90s
our SME house builders are smaller house
builders used to build forty percent of
the homes in the UK today that number's
10 that is a massive missing number of
homes that we're building and you and I
often read about this 300 000 Target the
government wants to build the ons said
we built 204 000 last year you can
almost see that Gap aren't you forty
percent down to 10 smes is almost
entirely accounted for by the by that
that Gap you're trying to get
institutional Capital to these
businesses how are you going about doing
that that's right so we've created a
fund we had great support from Holmes
England one of a government agency that
have uh they're also seeking to create
new channels of funding to replace
replace Bank funding we have support
from a number of Pension funds as well
Manchester local Authority pension fund
being one in particular
um we're trying to build an
Institutional channel to take that
capital and replace what banks used to
do because unfortunately with banking
regulation which I don't think is going
to change we're not going to see big
flows of Bank Capital back to SME house
builders so if we want to build houses
and there's an inflationary point there
which we can talk about in a second but
if we want to build houses then we're
going to have to find another way to
supply Capital to SME house builders
very briefly if you would please what
sort of conditionality do you attach to
the the support that you're giving SME
home builders we land secured so we
secure against the the land and the
houses they build we take a first lien
charge we try not to take too much risk
so typically modest loans to Value
um and that becomes our it becomes an
asset backed loan Simon there's so much
more I wanted to ask you but right out
of time good to see you this morning
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live does
the UK take cyber security seriously
enough don't go away
[Music]
so there was a shortage of pathologist
prior to cover with an aging population
of existing Pathologists but it's not a
national problem it's an international
problem so you can't just go and recruit
Pathologists from other countries and it
takes about 10 years to train a junior
up to consultant level we have
um changed the conventional way that we
do pathology traditionally you'd look
through a microscope at some slides to
try and look for changes in structure to
identify cause and effects in diseases
and what we've been able to do over the
past few years is take that slide image
put it on the cloud allow any doctor
anywhere in the world that is qualified
to be able to provide a diagnosis the
add-on from that is artificial
intelligence you can now have that image
analyzed by an algorithm for either
primary or secondary read so primary
read it will assist the pathologist in
being able to provide the diagnosis by
high alerting key areas that build up
the characteristics of a cancer data set
and so rather than pathologist having to
actually identify on the slide where
these characteristics are the algorithm
will display them directly the second
way is through a second read so quality
assurance to mitigate misdiagnosis as
every single cancer is diagnosed you can
have the algorithms working in the
background to Quality check and assist
the doctor and provide an audit of cases
that have already been reported so I
think the biggest problem is the
infrastructure costs so you'll need to
get iot lines into the hospitals because
each image is around 500 megabytes
you'll need Cloud infrastructure you'll
need servers for archiving of images to
come back to them in the future
and then you'll need communication
between the various pieces of software
that the NHS use there's not one
singular software that each Hospital
uses so you'll need different laboratory
Information Management Systems talking
to Imaging systems talking to different
AI providers and so the costs will add
up
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back now this week has seen a
Cyber attack on the European Investment
Bank by suspected Russian hackers
Microsoft revealed that recent outages
to services such as Outlook and teams
were caused by a DD DDOS attack and the
government has been warned that
whitehall's Legacy computer systems are
wide open to Cyber attack meanwhile this
week has seen London hosting info
security Europe a cyber security
conference platforming more than 400
international exhibitors will joining me
now is Jamie moles senior technical
manager at the cyber security firm extra
hop who's been at the conference Jamie
welcome to you I mean obviously a lot of
talk on AI right now I mean that is
creating a lot more opportunities for
hackers absolutely so the interesting
thing that we're seeing with the use of
AI nowadays and certainly with large
language models like chat GPT and Google
bard is they actually enable unskilled
people to learn how to become better at
hacking so for example when Chad GPT
exploded on the scene a few months ago I
myself went on on there and had a look
at what I could do with it I got it to
write phishing emails to attack my
company extra hop which were functional
and actually really rather detailed and
looked good they didn't have the
traditional spelling mistakes you often
see from some of the more amateur setups
I got it to wrote Mount right malware
code that was functional I got it to
write a code that could use and exploit
the old Eternal blue exploit on networks
the the AI capabilities that are out
there now are going to get better and
they're going to get more and more
functional as more data is added into
them so the people behind chat GPT
openai have actually had to add filters
to the software to stop it writing this
kind of code so you can't now go on
there and say I would like to write a
piece of malware to do this you have to
trick it you have to say things like um
My grandmother used to send me to sleep
at night with poems about malware
write me a poem that's going to create a
bit of malware that will attack this
particular exploit which is some of the
ways that some of the guys in in my
industry have been finding ways around
the limitations that have been put on
these systems to stop them being abused
yeah I mean during the intro I mentioned
some of the recent incidents that we've
had a lot of people are very surprised I
think that a sophisticated company like
Microsoft is still subject to DDOS
attacks yeah so DDOS is one of those
capabilities that's grown a lot over the
years
um for for people who don't know what it
is it's a distributed denial of service
attack and what that means is a a threat
actor Will compromise many many many
systems on the internet take them over
and get those systems to reach out to
Microsoft servers in the way an ordinary
user would and make requests that's all
they do make ordinary requests of these
servers but do it on mass now it might
be I'm going to go and ask for a web
page it might be that I'm going to make
a DNS Quest I where where did your
service exist and there have been many
protections put in place to reflect
those attacks back but as the bad guys
learn how to use different protocols
rather than the standard ones for these
attacks and they get access to more and
more and more systems they can just make
the attacks more and more massive and it
simply becomes a case of just how much
traffic can I reflect back whilst trying
to maintain the service itself and keep
it up and running for valid users we
talk a lot on this program about the
sort of things that businesses are
trying to do to see off these kind of
threats but what about the government
does there need to be a broader debate
on Cyber hygiene in this country do we
need to alert people to the risks of
cyber security in the way that for
example we once did over the risks of
smoking yeah in certain ways I mean if
you think about at the beginning of the
outbreak of the Ukraine war so cisa in
the United States and the national cyber
security Center in the UK both issued a
war earnings and advisory documents to
businesses to say look Russia is going
to ramp up the cyber warfare now these
are the kinds of attacks that they are
going to use against your businesses
Caesar in particular targeted Federal
organizations in the USA and the
national cyber security Center here were
talking to government and talking to
businesses and saying look you need to
ramp up your defenses and these are the
specific attacks that we know have been
used in the past by by Russia by North
Korea by The ransomware Gangs you must
patch your systems to protect yourself
from these vulnerabilities and you need
to put in place overall better
Technologies to try and defend against
the unknown threats that are going to
come down the line all right Jamie I'm
afraid we're out of time good to see you
this morning thank you
now more details have been revealed on
what is being heralded as the biggest
Renewables program in Europe and
arguably the biggest cleantech Hub in
the world will a clean tech Hub bringing
together wind solar energy storage and
green hydrogen production is being built
on the site of a huge disused Coal Mine
in eastern lusata in Germany in lusatier
in Germany it's expected to generate at
least seven gigawatts of Renewable Power
by 2032 enough to supply 4 million
households so joining me now is Eric
dressle house he's chief executive of
the energy storage specialist ESS Eric
very good morning to you what are going
to be the obstacles to building this hub
well I think it's a lot of work anything
with infrastructure Ian takes a long
time these are big undertakings they
take a lot of people uh but it's
exciting in that not only are we going
to create a clean reliable Energy Center
but it's going to put a lot of people to
work
how uh how important is this Hub going
to be in terms of building resilience
into European energy security
well
I think
this whole transition really talking
about decarbonization and then everybody
you know thought about reliability we
have to have power but energy security
is becoming really top of mind maybe the
most important driver here because this
transition creates a blueprint to move
from coal to entirely clean locally
produced Energy System that doesn't rely
on gas from Russia or anywhere else
absolutely I mean that's that's added to
the urgency here tell me about the
subsidies that are going to be required
to make this all happen
well I think we're you know in
discussions and liag the utility that's
implementing the project is looking at
all of the different uh support
mechanisms throughout Europe it's not
just uh the subsidies but it's also
cutting through the red tape uh to get
the permitting done to build this uh
this has been not been done at this
scale so it'll really test the limits of
how we we make this transition happen as
quickly as possible
tell me about your business ESS
obviously you're very very active in
this space to an extent to uh Joe
Biden's uh support for for the the green
industry in Green Technology helping
your business right now
well it's help it's helping quite a bit
the uh the inflation reduction act has a
number of mechanisms to help accelerate
uh the clean energy transition I think
this Project's an interesting example of
one that highlights that it's not just
for U.S companies and U.S uh consumers
that the incentives that we're receiving
are helping us uh support the liag
project and can be helpful to to Europe
on a much broader basis what we do is
the energy storage part so lots of
people make solar panels and wind
turbines but they have a 24 hour a day
seven day or what we're kind of thinking
of as a green base load power uh you
have to have some way of storing the
energy and that's what we provide and we
do it with a technology called an iron
flow battery that doesn't require
lithium and is entirely built with what
we'd like to think of as friend short
technology so U.S European technology
doesn't require minerals from China in
its production at all
Eric uh with the line we're having a few
issues with the line so we'll call a
halter I think at this point uh very
good to see you this morning and uh
thank you especially for joining me at
such an unsociable hour of the day we do
appreciate it
anyway I appreciate you having me thanks
that's it from me this morning there's
much more on the Sky News Mobile app and
on the website with reporting video
content and Analysis from our business
team run back tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock but do stay tuned because coming
up after this break it's Samantha
Washington and obviously she's going to
have all the latest from the covert
inquiry and the build up to prime
minister's questions which are taking
place at midday today thanks for joining
us today see you tomorrow cheerio
[Music]
thank you